[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues mme à cette question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics mais je vois qu'elle
s'adresse à muriel pénicaud
madame la ministre le gouvernement
semble poursuivre sans relâche un
objectif baisser le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités
il y a eu la hausse de la csg il y a eu
la souche indexation des retraites et
maintenant ce sont les déductions
fiscales accordées aux personnes âgées
de plus de 70 ans qui emploie une aide à
domicile qui sont dans le collimateur
décidément la personne âgée bien
malmenée par ce gouvernement privé les
personnes âgées des moyens qui leur
permettent d'être accompagnés dans leur
vie quotidienne et est une double erreur
à laquelle vous allez sans doute nous
confirmer que vous allez renoncer
d'abord parce que le vieillissement de
la population appelle des réponses
multiples et le rapport libos comme le
mien du reste ont démontré s'il en était
besoin que le maintien à domicile reste
une priorité absolue pour le bien-être
des personnes âgées et pour l'équilibré
des finances publiques
ce projet était aussi une faute parce
que faire des retraités les nouveaux
boucs émissaires n'est pas digne les
personnes âgées méritent notre respect
vous ne devez pas vous ne pouvez pas les
considérer comme une variable
d'ajustement budgétaire il a été annoncé
que vous reculiez sur la suppression des
avantages fiscaux qui concernait les
aides à domicile
c'est du reste conforme à ce que
monsieur d'arman avait déclaré sur rmc
le 6 février dernier
à l'époque il n'était pas favorable à ce
que d'éventuelles suppressions de niches
fiscales touche les emplois à domicile
et on ne pouvait qu'être d'accord
j'espère madame la ministre que cet
épisode de va et vient pdt le peu
glorieux pour le gouvernement va nous
éclairer sur le sens que vous devez
donner à la réforme des retraites ne pas
toucher au pouvoir d'achat des retraités
nous espérons tous madame la ministre
faut que cette volte face sera
l'occasion pour le gouvernement de
renforcer tous ceux qui contribuent
à permettre le maintien des personnes
âgées à leur domicile pouvez vous nous
dire où en est le gouvernement sur ces
sujets pour vous répondre la parole et à
madame la ministre du travail